let me
return us back to planet nine uh-huh
always a good place to come back to
so now that we did a big historical
overview of our solar system what is
planet nine okay planet nine
is a hypothetical object that orbits the
solar system
right at an orbital period of about ten
thousand years
and uh an orbit which is slightly tilted
with respect to the plane of the solar
system slightly eccentric and the object
itself
we think is five times more massive than
the earth we have never seen planet nine
in a telescope but we have gravitational
evidence for it
and so this is where all the stuff we've
been talking about this clustering ideas
maybe you can speak to the approximate
location that we
suspect and also the question i wanted
to ask is uh
what are we supposed to be imagining
here because he said there's certain
objects in the kuiper belt that are kind
of have a direction to them that they're
all
like like flocking in some kind of way
so that's the sense that there's some
kind of gravitational object
not changing their orbit but kind of
confining them right
yeah finding like grouping their orbits
together see what would happen if planet
nine were not there
is these orbits that roughly share a
common orientation
they would just disperse right they're
just become as
a mutually symmetric point everywhere
planet nine's gravity
makes it such that these objects stay
in a state that's that's basically
anti-aligned with respect to the orb
of planet nine um and
and sort of hang out there and kind of
oscillate on time scale of about a
billion years
that's one of the lines of evidence for
the existence of planet nine there are
others that's the one that's easiest to
maybe visualize just because it's fun to
think about orbits that all point
into the same direction but i should um
you know emphasize that for example the
existence of
objects again kuiper belt objects that
are heavily out of the plane
of the solar system things that are
tilted by say 90 degrees that's not
we don't expect that as an outcome
of planet formation indeed plant
information
simulations have never produced such
objects
without some extrinsic gravitational
force
planet 9 on the other hand generates
them very readily so that
provides kind of an alternative you know
population of small bodies in the solar
system that also get produced by planet
9 through an
independent kind of gravitational effect
so they're kind of
there's basically five different things
that the uh that planet nine does
individually that are like kind of
maybe a one sigma effect where you would
say yeah okay if that's all it was
maybe it's not no reason to jump up and
down but because
it's it's mult it's a multitude of these
puzzles
that all are explained by one hypothesis
that's that's really the the magnetism
the attraction of the planet nine model
so can you just clarify so
most orbit most planets in the solar
system orbit
and approximately the same so it's flat
yeah it's like
one degree they the difference between
them is
about one degree so but nevertheless if
we looked at our solar system it would
look
and i could see every single object it
would look like a sphere
the inner part where the planets are
would look
like you know flat right the the kuiper
belt
and the asteroid belt have a larger
um it gets fatter and fatter yeah that's
kind of like there's a sphere
that's right and if you look at the very
outside it's polluted by this
you know quasi-spheroidal thing
nobody's of course ever seen the oort
cloud
right we've only seen comments that come
from the oort cloud so
the oort cloud which is this right
population of distant debris
its existence is also inferred you could
say
alternatively there is you know there's
a big cosmic creature
that occasionally you know sitting at 20
000 au and occasionally throws an icy
rock towards the sound like that
spaghetti monster i think it's called
okay i mean so it's a mystery
in many ways but you can kind of infer a
bunch of things about it
it's it's by the way both terrifying and
exciting that there's this
vast darkness all around us that's full
of objects that are just
throwing just there yeah it's actually
kind of astonishing right that
we have only explored
a small fraction of the solar system
right
that that really kind of baffles me
because
uh i remember as a student you know
studying physics you know
you do the problem where you put the
earth around the sun you solve that and
like it's one line of math and you say
okay well that
surely was figured out by newton so like
all the interesting stuff
is not in the solar system but that um
it's just plainly not true there are
there are mysteries
in the solar system that are remarkable
that we are only now starting to just
kind of scratch the surface of
and some of those objects probably have
some information about the history of
our solar system
absolutely absolutely like a great
example is
um you know small meteorites right small
meteorites
are melted right they have they're
differentiated meaning some of the
uh iron sinks you say well how can that
be
because they're so small that they
wouldn't have melted just from the heat
of their accretion
turns out the fact that the solar nebula
the
the disc that made the planets was
polluted by
aluminum 26 is in itself a remarkable
thing it means
the solar system did not form in
isolation it formed
in a giant cloud of thousands of other
stars that were also forming
some of which were undergoing you know
going through supernova explosions some
of
and releasing these unstable isotopes
um that of which we now see kind of the
traces of
it's so cool
you